大家好好,
我是Jim,
這裡是Jim AI Notebook,
今天來聊DeepSeek V4.1 Flash,
看到Flash這個名字,
你可能跟我一樣,
第一個想到的就是快,
回復比較快,
等待時間比較短,
或者是一個便宜一點能力也稍微弱一點的版本,
但看完這份技術報告,
我覺得最值得聊的,
是他怎麼處理越來越長的內容,
你如果用過Coding Agent,
應該很熟悉這個過程,
叫他改一個功能,
他先讀程式碼,
再看文件,
跑完測試,
還要把錯誤訊息讀回來,
事情還沒做完,
對話裡已經塞了一大堆東西,
他還沒做完,
對話裡已經塞了一大堆東西
這些內容模型都得處理
而且下一步還可能再用到
任務做得越久
背後的負擔就越重
v4.1 Flash花了很大力氣
把這部分的成本壓下來
按照官方公佈的數字
它的全局KB Cache
大約只剩上一代的四分之一
在幾項程式開發和自動化測試裡
成績也已經接近旗艦模型
所以今天我們就來看
它到底省了什麼
又為了省下這些成本
改了哪些地方
我們先從最實際的問題開始
便宜
大家當然喜歡
但前提是事情要做得完
以前講到flash這類模型
常見的用法是把比較簡單的工作交給他
分類
整理格式
回答短問題
遇到難題
再換能力更強
價格更高的模型
LIFO等於flash
這個分工沒那麼容易劃清楚
從官方的測試來看
一些需要堵城市馬
使用工具
連續執行很多步驟的工作
他已經有相當好的表現
如果你平常跑的任務
剛好落在這個範圍
選模型時就會多想一下
我還需要每一步都用最貴的那個嗎
不過這不代表旗艦已經沒有用途
官方目前的定價業仍然保留Visual Pro
也顯明會繼續提供API服務
光看產品安排
還不能下結論說Flash已經全面取代Pro
真正要比較的
還是你交給他的那件事
他做了什麼
先看成績單
官方把他跟Opus 5、GP Tifa 6、Soul Kimi K3等模型放在一起
表格標示的是各模型最高推理強度的結果
Visual屌與Flash比較亮眼的
是幾項需要實際操作的測試
例如修改真實程式碼的Deep SWE
他的分數略高於Opus 5
Terminal Bench 2.1
就是命令列裡完成任務的測試
它排在這張表的最前面
Automation Bench的自動化任務
表現也很好
但換一批題目
差距就出來了
愛不使用工具的Humanities Last Exam
也就是人類最後測驗裡
VSO.1 Flash是36.8分
Opus I是56.3分
差了將近20分
而且就算同樣是命令列任務
也不能一概而論
Terminal Bench 5.1
它領先換到4.0
它是31.2分
Opus I則是51.8分
所以我會說
他已經很擅長某些agent工作
但還不能把這句話擴大成只要能用工具
他就跟最強的模型一樣
測試內容一換
能力上的差異還是看得見
報告裡也有一段
專門談他目前還做的不夠好的地方
第一個是科學類的長任務
這些工作往往需要很深的領域知識
而且一路推進
不能中間哪一步想做就整件事跑偏
這部分他跟更大的模型還有距離
第二個是視覺能力
看圖理解圖表
他已經能做
也贏過部分統計的開放模型
但跟最前面的閉元系統相比
第三個則跟我們怎麼看跑分有關
報告提醒
有些測試已經接近飽和
分數很接近
不表示模型在真實世界裡的能力就完全相同
這點其實很實用
你平常交給agent的任務
不會剛好都是排行榜上的題目
他會不會誤解需求走到一半卡住
需要你提醒好幾次
這些都會影響你最後覺得他好不好用
接下來架構說明
主要來自DeepSeek自己發佈的技術報告
它是一份51頁的官方報告
我們會把裡面的測試結果
當成開發團隊提供的證據來看
官方測試有參考價值
但不能直接當成所有結果都已經被第三方重現
後面講到獨立時測試
我會另外說明來源
這份報告的標題翻成中文
大概是把KVCash的壓縮推到極限
光看標題知道它的重點放在哪裡
KVCash是模型處理上下文時保留的一組中間資料
名字現在不用急著記
等一下會分開講
先補一個單位
報告裡的長度和價格用的都是Token
你可以把它理解成模型處理文字的基本單位
但一個Token不一定等於一箇中文字
所以這一代資源的100萬長度
值了是100萬個Token
它還能直接接收圖片
屬於多模態模型
要理解它為什麼省
先把模型的工作分成兩個階段
你送出一段內容之後
模型會先處理輸入
這個階段叫Prefill
中文通常翻成預填
如果你貼了一份很長的文件
它就得先把這份文件算過一遍
接下來模型才開始逐步產生新的Token
這個階段叫Decode
也就是解碼
你看到回答一段一段出現
主要就是這個過程
兩個階段對硬體的需求不太一樣
預填可以同時處理很多輸入位置
假碼則的
接著前一步的結果
繼續產生下一個Token
對的來說
預填尤其重要
因為它每做一步
可能都會拿到新的資料
檔案內容
搜尋結果
工具回傳
測試記錄
等到下一次呼叫模型
這些東西又會成為輸入的一部分
你最後看到的答案也許只有幾段
中間處理過的內容卻可能非常多
E4.1 Flash的設計
就是很明確地朝這種工作形態去優化
這臺模型的主幹有40層
分成前20層和後20層
你可以把一層理解成一個處理階段
資料經過每一層
都會繼續被轉換
最後用來預測下一個Token
這40層裡
有些計算會用到很前面的內容
有些只關注最近的一小段
為了讓後續生成不用反覆重算
系統會把部分中間結果
留在顯示卡記憶體裡
如果希望下次遇到相同的前綴時
也能重用
也可以把快取保存到其他儲存空間
例如主機記憶體或SSD
所以接下來
你只要抓住幾個問題就好
哪些層一定要算
哪些資料可以共用
每一份要存多大
以及下次還要不要繼續留著
這一代大部分的改動
都能放回這幾個問題來理解
模型產生下一個token時
會透過注意力機制
使用前面內容的資訊
如果前面的中間結果
每次都重新計算
生成檔回答的成本就會很高
因此係統會把注意力機制
需要的key和value保留下來
叫做KV cache
中文叫見值快取
你可以暫時把它想成
模型讀的內容後留下的筆記
不過它存的是數值表示
並不是一份人看得懂的摘要
這份快取讓模型省下大量重算
但也帶來另一個問題
上下文越長
需要保留的資料通常就越多
如果每一層都留一份
很多個使用者又同時在跑場任務
顯示卡記憶體很快就會吃緊
而且存得下還不夠
生成時還得把需要的資料讀出來
這又牽涉到記憶體頻寬
所以壓縮KB Cache
省到的是儲存空間
也可能減少讀取資料的負擔
這就是它值得花這麼多篇幅處理的原因
第一個改動
是前面提到的20層加20層
E4.E Flash
採用Costal Encoder Decoder
簡稱CED
也就是因果編碼器解碼器架構
報告提到
設計受到UQO研究的啟發
前20層負責處理輸入
後20層需要了全局KBH
則從前半段最後的輸出投影得到
後半段就不用為了建立全局快取
再把整份輸入完整跑一次
這裡的Costal
是說每個位置只能使用自己和前面的資訊
不能看到後面還沒出現的內容
它跟我們平常講的因果推理是兩回事
這個分工帶來的結果是
預填時每個Token
啟用的參數大約是80億
到了生成階段
前後40層的銀顏都要參與
啟用參數大約是160億
但後半段也不是完全不用處理輸入
最近那一小段的局部快取
還有需要補算的部分
因此
這裡可以說預填的計算量接近減半
但不能直接換算成
你每次問問題都會快一倍
實際還省多少
要看輸入多長輸出多長
以及系統當時的負債
第二個改動
事實上不同層共用部分資料
一般來說各層的表示不同
各自保存快取有它的理由
但如果架構和訓練方式配合得好
就不一定每一層都得保留獨立的一份
v4.1 Flash用的是
Compress Sparse Attention Tool
簡稱CSA桶
它把注意力層分成三種模式
完整模式會建立快取
也會挑出這次要讀取的重點位置
紅條模式沿用前面建立的快取
但重新挑一次位置
沿用模式則連挑選結果都直接共用
差別就在於
這一層究竟需要重新算多少東西
40層裡
最前面兩層只看局部範圍
其餘38層會使用全局資訊
而這38層的全局快取
筆記只對應四組
前半段三組
後半段一組
這不表示可以直接拿38除以4
就算出相對上一代省了幾倍
因為上一代已經有壓縮設計
各組快取的大小也不一定相同
另外上一代V4
混用了兩種注意力設計
這一代統一成一種
對工程師做來說
統一之後
比較容易把程式和執行效率一起調好
快取可以共用
挑選資料的動作本身也得夠便宜
吸收注意力的概念
是每次只讀取一部分比較相關的內容
但要知道哪些內容相關
還是得先搜尋
如果每一層都把全部位置掃過一遍
上下文一場
光是挑選就會很花時間
他們因此加上分層的索引機制
先由前面負責建立候選集合的層
做一次比較粗的篩選
後續需要重新挑選的層
就從這個候選集合裡繼續找
不必每次都掃完整份上下文
這個做法有點像查一本很厚的書
先確定可能再拿幾個章節
再進去找細節
會比從第一頁一路翻快的多
它的好處是
後續這些索引層要處理的候選數量
可以被限制住
不會隨著上下吻長度一路增加
不過每次最多挑512個壓縮後的條目
不代表系統只保存512個條目
其他快取還在
下一次查詢可能就會用到
這招主要省的是搜尋和讀取
不然它理解成其他記憶都刪掉了
接下來是量化
也就是用更少的位元存同一組數值
E4.0 Flash把主要的全局KP Cache
從8位元改成4位元格式
這一張數值本身的體積就少了一半
但實際計算時還要加上縮放係數
它的作用是記錄這一組數字的尺度
讓比較粗的數字格式仍然能涵蓋需要的範圍
這一代的配置是每16個數值
共用一個8位元的縮放係數
攤下來每個數值平均需要4.5個位元
做量化時最怕的就是省了空間
能力也一起掉下去
因此他們在後段訓練就讓模型適應這種格式
這叫量化感知訓練
模型有機會在訓練過程中
學者處理量化帶來的誤差
通常會比最後才突然壓縮更有餘裕
至於比較敏感的局部快取
他們那年保留8位元
按照報告的結果
這套配置造成的能力損失很小
把前面的共享和壓縮加在一起
就得到這份報告最重要的數字之一
每個Token的根據KV Cash
只需要890個位元主
大約是上一代V4 Flash的四分之一
換成比較容易想象的容量
100萬個Token
大約對應0.89GB的全局快取
先提醒一下
這只是全局KV Cash
模型權重局部快取
執行時的暫存空間
全部都還要另外算
所以這不代表整臺模型
不到1GB就能跑
它真正影響的是
同樣一批顯示卡
可以留它多少空間
給上上下文
以及同時處理多少個請求
假設瓶頸主要就在
這一部分的快取
容量縮到四分之一
容納的上下文總量
就有機會大幅增加
但整套服務
能不能多接四倍使用者
還要看算力平寬
和加機一體開銷
比較有意思的是
這一代的主幹參數
其實變多了
這部分的快取反而變小
模型有多大
跟每次處理場內容有多貴
已經不能只看同一個數字
除了生成當下放在顯示卡上的快取
還有一種成本
是把快取保存下來
請求可以重用
VSO.me Flash在這裡做了一個取捨
局部注意力用到的那份快取
不再長期保存到SSD
需要的時候
再用最近的一小段內容把它重建出來
因為局部注意力只看附近的內容
太前面的資料
不會直接參與這一層的局部計算
所以重建不必從整份文件的開頭開始
但多層疊起來影響範圍還是會往前延伸
按照報告的設定
要完整還原
會涉及20層乘上128個Token
也就是約2560個Token的範圍
他們實際採用的是隻重跑最近的一個窗口
接收一點近似誤差
這個方法叫Bonded Replay
可以理解成限制重播的範圍
這裡要講清楚
它跟完整重算在數學上並不相等
報告的做法
其實在後段訓練就模擬這種重建方式
讓模型適應並檢查造成的影響
局部快取不用長期存
有下來的全局快取又更小
兩個效果合起來
持久保存的KB Cash
大約降到上一代的八分之一
前面主要在省讀取和記憶體
輸出速度則還有另一套做法
正常生成時
模型每產生一個Token都要跑一次計算
要讓它更快
一個常見的方法
是先用比較小的模型提出一串候選
再交給主模型一起驗證
這叫投機結碼
例如小模型先拆後面5個Token
主模型就可以在A輪裡檢查這幾個候選
前面連續通過的部分可以接受
遇到不符合接受條件的位置再修正並繼續生成
如果草稿經常被接受
就能省下主模型足夠深層的回合
拆得不好
也會增加白做的工作
V4.1 Flash的草稿模型叫D-Spark
它會估計候選被接受的幾率
再配合系統負債
調整這一輪驗證的長度
因此策略不一定永遠都是拆得越多越好
服務同時有很多請求時
還得考慮整批硬體的吞吐量
而且這一套是在主幹訓練完成之後
另外安排階段訓練的
跟上一代把相關模組一起訓練的做法不同
架構設計員
還得看它在顯示卡上怎麼執行
模型的一層
通常包含很多小段運算
這些在GPU上執行的小程式
叫Kernel
也就是核心程式
如果每個步驟都分開執行
就可能多出啟動成本
也可能需要把中間結果寫回記憶體
下一個步驟再讀出來
所以常見的優化
是把適合接在一起的運算合併
讓資料留在更靠近運算單元的地方
少搬幾次
這一代也花了不少力氣做這件事
報告指出
對
佔多數的沿用模式層來說
譬如說,預填每層只需要15次Kernel呼叫,解碼則是11次
這兩個數字,你不需要背
重點是前面那些共用和省略最後真的反應到直航程式裡
否則架構圖上看起來省很多,實際跑的時候一直搬資料,一直等待,效果還是會打的
再往外看,就是整套服務怎麼部署
一次多模態請求
可以分成幾個工作
先把圖片轉成模型能使用的表示,再處理整份輸入
最後逐步產生回答
而v4.1 Flash把視覺編碼、預填和解碼分開部署
讓不同階段使用各自的資源
安排的理由很直接
玉田通常比較吃算力
逐步解碼時
記憶體頻寬往往很重要
圖片處理的需求則會隨請求內容變動
如果全部綁在一起
某一段忙不過來時
其他資源未必能有效幫上忙
分開之後
就能比較有針對性的增加資源
也比較容易安排不同請求同時進行
例如一個請求還在生成回答
另一個請求可以先在玉田的機器上處理輸入
當然
分開也會有資料傳輸和排程成本
它的價值在於
當服務規模夠大
各階段需求又不同時
可以把硬體用得更有效率
講了這麼多回答大家最直覺的問題
用起來到底快不快
這裡要分開看幾個指標
輸出開始之後
每秒能產生多少Token
送出請求之後
多久收到第一個Token
以及整個任務要花多久才能完成
這三件事不一樣
我查到的Artificial Analysis
面面VSO.Flash
在DeepSeq官方API上的輸出速度
大約是每秒213個Token
首個Token的時間大約是1.13秒
首個Token不一定就是你想看的正式答案
如果模型先推理
從開始回傳到真正回答
中間還可能有一段時間
這些數字也會隨服務負債、測試條件和版本更新有變動
我會把連結放在諮詢欄
技術報告更想強調的則是長度增加之後的計算量
按照報告的結果
上下文從約4000個Token拉到約100萬
長度增加約256倍
每個輸出Token的計算量只增加約1 4分之1
這不代表整份輸入免費
也不代表延遲只增加1 4分之1
它說明的是上下文變長之後
後續每一步生成需要增加的計算被控制住
到這裡可能已經有不少名詞了
我們把它們放回同一個流程看
收到場輸入時
CED先減少預點需要跑的計算
處理過的全局資訊
透過跨層共用和量化
縮小保存的體積
後續要取用資料時
再用分層索引減少搜尋範圍
需要重用先前的上下文
就載入保留下來的全局快取
局部狀態則用最近的內容重建
開始生成之後
再交給DISPARK提出候選
減少主模型逐個輸出的回合
底下還有Colonel合併和分離部署
負責把這些設計有效的跑起來
他們解決的是不同環節的成本
也會互相配合
像快取縮小
除了比較省記憶體
跨機器傳輸時也比較輕
這些效果加在一起
才是整套系統能便宜下來的原因
再看一次模型規模
會發現一個容易搞混的地方
上一代V4 Flash的主幹參數是2841
這一代增加到5521
接近兩倍
但它是MOE模型
每個Token不會用到全部參數
再加上前面說的CED
預填時啟用約80億參數
解碼時則是約161
上一代的啟用參數是約131
也就是說這一代在讀取和生成時的數字不同
挑帕11那個數字
拿來代表所有使用情境
另外
它還有一個叫engram的條件記憶模組
配置了1961參數
透過稀疏查找來存取
這也提醒我們
看參數量時要確認
數字算的是主幹
也是包含其他模組
多模態訓練方面
它從語言模型預訓練開始
就一起處理文字和圖片表示
訓練語調規模是45兆個token
最後看知識能力
部分基礎模型測試已經接近V4 Pro
但不是每一項都追評
它的效率確實提升了
能力範圍人要一項一項看
推論效率之外
還有另一個問題
它怎麼練出這些agent能夠在後訓練這一段
講得很明確
這次沒有修改後訓練演算法
主要改動集中在資料流程
訓練能源連用SFT強化學習
以及On Policy Distillation
也就是讓模型在自己產生的軌跡上
接受老師模型的指導
真正花力氣的地方
是大量產生agent任務和環境
再逐步擴大資料
任務種類
以及實際跑過的軌跡
對agent來說
這件事很重要
光有一份問答資料
不足以呈現完整的工作過程
還需要看到怎麼使用工具
怎麼根據結果決定下一步
也需要遇到失敗之後
還能繼續處理的情境
我的解讀是
當一套訓練方法已經夠用
把資料和環境做得更完整
您有很大的進步空間
但沒有改後訓練演算法
說的是這一段訓練流程
前面那些模型架構
和推論系統的改動
仍然是這一代的重要工作
這些優化
對使用者最直接的影響
還是價格
目前官方把費用分成
快取命中的輸入
沒有命中的輸入
以及輸出三類
而且還有尖峰和離峰價格
以E4.1 Flash來說
每100萬個輸入Token
快取命中時是0.15到0.3美元
快取命中時是0.003到0.006美元
每100萬個輸出Token
則是0.6到1.2美元
離峰是尖峰的一半
不過時段是照官方的UTC規則劃分
不能直接理解成你所在地的半夜才便宜
對反覆讀取相同程式碼和文件的agent來說
能不能命中快取會明顯影響賬單
同樣是跑時輪
前面的內容能重用多少
成本可能差很多
至於V4 Pro
目前仍列在定價頁上
官方也說會繼續提供服務
因此
我不會把這次更新解讀成旗艦已經被淘汰
比較實際的變化是
你現在可以用較低的單價
嘗試把更多工作交給模型
最後值不值得
還是要把成功率
從事次數
和整個任務的花費
一起算進去
如果你自己會寫程式
也已經在用agent
我覺得它值得拿來
跑你手上的長任務
尤其是那些
要反覆讀取同一份專案
檢查測試結果
繼續修改的工作
挑幾個你熟悉的案例
比較它最後
有沒有做對
花多久
整個任務花多少錢
如果你是在公司裡
評估導入
這次更新
比較值得注意的是
某些原本成本
太高的流程
可能可以重新估算
不過估算時
要把人工介入
也算進去
模型便宜很多
但如果沒跑幾步
就要有人接手
省下的API費用
不一定補得回來
如果你不寫程式
只是想知道
這件事為什麼重要
可以這樣看
當AI要處理的工作
越來越長
光是答得好還不夠
它也得能負擔整個過程
這一代展示的
就是怎麼從架構和系統裡
直接反覆出現的成本
一點一點降下來
回到最開始
那個coding agent的例子
他讀了程式碼
文件和測試結果之後
接下來每一步
都可能需要前面的資訊
如果保存和使用
用這些資訊的代價太高
任務就很難一路做下去
VSOAR.EFLASH
在這裡提供了一個具體做法
減少預填的重複計算
讓快取跨層共用
壓低每份資料的體積
再限制後續搜尋的範圍
這些設計讓上
上下文比較容易負擔
但不代表內容可以無限制的塞
也不代表塞得越多
模型就一定做得越好
怎麼整理資訊
什麼時候保留
什麼時候移除
仍然是Agen的設計的一部分
所以FLASH到底FLASH在哪
從這份報告來看
他很重要的一個優勢
是能把長任務裡
不斷增加的記憶體和計算負擔
壓得比以前更低
你交給他更多內容之後
後續生成不必跟著付出
同樣比例的計算成本
這才是我覺得
比單看每秒輸出幾個Token
更值得理解的地方
看完這份報告
我會更想
完成一件事
要多少成本來比較模型
回答能力很重要
按輸入要讀多久
快取佔多少空間
工具用的幾輪
失敗要重跑幾次
最後都會影響
這個模型能不能真的拿來工作
MIFU.flash的幾項agent成績已經很有競爭力
在更難的推理、科學和部分視覺任務上
也還有明顯的進步空間
對我來說現在最值得做的
就是把它放進真實任務
看看這些效率上的改善
能不能一起轉成穩定的產出
如果換成你
你會先拿哪一件工作來試
改程式、整理大量文件
還是讓它跑一個完整的自動化流程
留言跟我分享
喜歡這類技術報告解說
也可以訂閱Jim & Notebook
我是Jim,我們下次見